[Applaudissements]
mon frère a perdu la fille en
pourchassant les demies
sa quête est aujourd'hui la plaine
colère
[Musique]
accompagné moi
soyez à mes côtés
seulement ce n'est ni le hasard
ni la destinée
notre rencontre est bien plus important
que ça
[Musique]
chacun de nous
chacun d'entre nous
on se doit de décider quel chemin
emprunter
[Musique]
je ne suis pas le héros que vous
cherchez
qu'importe ce que vous avez pu faire
libérer vos de tout cela un jour tout
ceci sera ton royaume
vous
ne choisissez pas le chemin de la peur
mais celui de la foi
[Musique]
s'il ya bien une chose qu'on sait faire
mieux que n'importe quelle créature de
la terre du milieu
c'est se soutenir les uns les autres
avec le coeur
encore plus grand que les pieds
nous allons surmonter cette épreuve
vous et moi
[Musique]
commandant attendait non nous devons
continuer
pourquoi quand il met vous à vous battre
il y à une tempe être moi
vous avez assez combattu galadriel
ranger votre épée
[Musique]
mais qui suis-je son épée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya des tirs dans le 10e
arrondissement des rues les rues de noix
les rues et louise est en ligne avec la
pp reste au bureau il te retrouves tout
le monde ya une équipe au stade de
france et l'autre damparis a attiré rue
bichat au carillon rue de la fontaine au
rang séverine tu pars au stade de france
avec ton équipe intéressante au bataclan
en plein concert
[Applaudissements]
on est évidemment préparé pour ça mais
ceux pour qui la charge émotionnelle est
trop importantes peuvent se mettre sur
le côté
je veux pas qu'on laisse place à nos
émotions personnelles aux dernières
informations il y aurait deux
terroristes en fuite dans paris
je veux que le moindre type qui a eu un
comportement bizarre dans les dernières
24 heures soit en garde à vue
faisait quoi le soir du 13 novembre
tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est clamé qui vous frappe
encore nous frapper
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone pour une
autre livraison d'or
tout est lié c'est quoi son nom
je ne connais on n'a rien sur lui
comment vous l'avez récupérer l'adresse
je les suis vous avez travaillé en
dehors de toute procédure
numéro 3 la rassemblent toi moi j'ai
besoin de voir
comment est ce possible que vous n'ayez
rien ça fait trois jours maintenant
je sais que sont les deux terroristes
le nom de la victime et léo copernic
les victimes ont été tuées dans le local
à costumes
ensuite a été déplacé
ce qui est une sorte de mise en scène
combien de temps pensez-vous encore
devoir vous garder l'idée est-elle la
rassembler tous les suspects puis nous
interroger à tour de rôle jusqu'à ce que
le mystère soirée zouk mervyn concarneau
restreint nature jeu dur estimé
dramaturge 13 estimez vous voyez désolé
j'ai du mal à relire mon écriture est
bien eu un incident
jurait pour ça c'est une confession ne
tirons pas de conclusions hâtives
pour une surprise vous travaillez tas
ou le fastueux copernic pour dissimuler
son aventure on a notre tueur au pardon
je lis encore fait
j'ai tiré des conclusions hâtives
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler de
richard attenborough un véritable
enquêteurs
y avait il une raison particulière à
cette animosité
[Musique]
c'était moi inspecteurs je vous arrête
pour le meurtre de lyon nous avons un
tueur en série en liberté
volley reculer attendez il caché
sous le paillasson
nous ne sommes plus seulement des
suspects
nous sommes ici
potentiellement des victimes
qu'at-il fait qui vous a semblé suspect
n'était pas tant ce qu'il faisait mais
c'était plutôt le bel la façon dont il
le faisait comment faisait-il de façon
suspecte bien
on va présenter là dedans
ok on va décoller mais attendent entre
sausset la porte est ouverte la coupe
préféré fermer ah oui par exemple l'ugta
de plus tu as de pital
tous les deux
je vous vois
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'ils aient
tous les sur livre
[Rires]
bien des sites à sonar toute dernière
génération
ça y est la partie plus vite que prévu
ça n'a
pas pu survivre accueilli qui paraît
dans mes pc votera jamais pour moi quand
j'ai voulu se faire connaître les taux
votre fils sera entre de bonnes mains c
[Musique]
jusque là
l'imec matt et moi ça on est au paradis
[Musique]
traire de salies à la vie à la mort
nos règles sont claires
et celui qui les emprunts
devra en subir les conséquences
c'est de la trahison
je hais cet endroit t'as pas entendu
parler de l'histoire du loup le
proviseur cacherait quelque chose de
terrifiant dans les sous sols
[Musique]
il se passe ici des choses étranges
qu'est ce que tu racontes
je dois te demander quelques
[Musique]
cachez-vous il faut qu on s'échappe
dante le loup n'est pas là
car s'il vous trouve elle votait devra
tous
[Musique]
pourquoi vous êtes ici délits sexuels
répétés de nature extrêmement violente
voilà pourquoi je suis ici
il est extrêmement manipulateurs je te
plaît c'est ça
qu'est ce qui se passe entre toi et
idriss
quelque chose je résiste ou
vous suivez
tes ennemis de nancy
d'or cramif sociaux
oui
sonnent
[Musique]
nous pensions que la bataille
était désormais derrière nous
aujourd'hui
la paix se profile
nous pensions que nos joies j'amène un
finirait
nous pensions que notre lumière jamais
s'éteindre et lesieu
[ __ ] et rohr
[Musique]
car l'adriatique fine art in le moment
tant redouté
[Musique]
le mal ne dort jamais
il patiente
dans les profondeurs la pénombre peut
tous nous engloutir sous la montagne
notre ennemi à bien des noms
tu as entendu parler de lui tu connais
le nom de sauron
si le mal qui s'élèvent en terre du
millionnaire maîtrisé il va se répandre
et tous nous avertir
trouve la lumière est jamais l'ombre ne
trouveras
ensemble nous pouvons gagner
combattez avec moi
chacun d'entre nous se doit de décider
quel chemin il devra emprunter
il ne peut y avoir de confiance entre un
marteau une pierre
un
beau jour l'un ou l'autre on viendra se
briser
vous à compter tant de mensonges sur la
terre du milieu
[Musique]
by jo
c'est de ce soir à
saint ouen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rosanara quoi
[Musique]
maquet
odier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je serai
[Musique]
c'est la méga buzz danic de mes 29 ans
c'est toujours les trucs de malade là je
trouve que c'est tombé le week-end qui
comprend disparue au portel
[Musique]
jobs au sunny j'arrive
on retrouve en position étoiles de mer
et mes toiles ça vole france
[Musique]
las vegas question mais 44 ans et je
suis trop content d'avoir discuté avec
toi on se capte bientôt ok allez dites
au revoir
les enfants dites à votre mère que vous
allez vous débrouiller sans moi pour
être honnête j'y mets quelques doutes
désolé maman mais c'est pas brillé cette
semaine son père aura du temps libre
je vais m'offrir du temps libre d'autant
montant montant ces montants
camarades bêta
optison il peut jurer que ce sera la
meilleure semaine de toute la ville
où sont les toilettes juste là ça c'est
une pile de sautant prend 1 tu puisses
tu l'as tu le vis de son bord de la
route je te laisse te débrouiller
mythique
pourquoi tu veux réduire enfants le
campement ont fait construire une
immense statue à son effigie alors que
tu me dois ans traqué
[Musique]
parce que personne ne panique mais pas
que
m
ces individus sont rendus
j'espère
[Musique]
allez voir sur scène
messieurs
j'ai l'immense honneur de vous présenter
le huitième merveille du monde
le cerf est l'unique
le
cube abonnés
ça mérite bien
tu es presque un vrai gars ans
tourne toi que je regarde si tout va
bien je serai à la maison et quand tu
reviendras pinocchio pour les rues tout
seul sans une conscience vous imaginez
les menaces qui pèsent sur lui je
n'aimerais pas voir ça sur ma conscience
d'une personne qui n'est pas personne en
vie d'être de personnes je vais être un
vrai garçon pourquoi diable veux tu être
vrai alors que tu peux être
[Musique]
deux critères le petit devrait être
entre eux
[Musique]
tu seras plus une marionnette envoie
garantie sur facture
[Musique]
non
c'est
pinocchio
soit braves
général
et digne de confiance
tu seras jamais mon vrai petit garçon
[Musique]
mensonge peut vraiment transformé
quelqu'un qu'est-ce qui se pose du min
on dirait de la magie féerique à vue de
nez ça y ressemble bien
le peuple du cheval est une tribu de
l'est
il leur donnait d'envoyer en masse des
alchimistes d'état sur le front en tant
qu'arme de destruction
ce fut un véritable massacre
il a une cicatrice
étaient des alchimistes de haut niveau
et des combattant émérite quant à moi
j'ai été envoyé par dieu en tant
qu'instrument de son jugement divin ce
type est dangereux
je détruirai quiconque osera se mettre
entre moi et ma mission
[Musique]
c'est vous qui avez tué mes parents
je vais devenir à secret en gage de ma
gratitude quelque chose de terrible va
arriver ce que
tu apprendras étrangers que tu ne peut
agir à sa guise dans mon pays vrai par
toi
[Musique]
oh
mais qu'est ce que vous avez à klaxonner
comme ça je suis prête
avenue dechavanne à courbevoie traverser
tout paris vous êtes au courant si
c'était à côté je ne vous aurais pas
appelé c'est l'ajout de neige
st80
charmeur
g92 les médecins pensent que c'est mieux
pour moi que je sois dans un
établissement à temps
[Musique]
vous en verrez pas qu'on fasse un petit
détour par vincennes cependant ce moment
je sais je sais j'aimerais revoir mon
ancien quartier
au caire
le premier rhum que j'embrassais scène
matt j'étais en septembre 44
tout en un éclair
76 ans après j'ai toujours le goût de
ses baisers sur mes lèvres
ça fait 30 ans que j'ai pas fumer
aujourd'hui c'est spécial
vous savez ce que mon père me disait
chaque colère est à coup de vieux
[Musique]
man
chaque sourire est un coup de jeune
je veux que vous sachiez que ce voyage
en taxi
[Musique]
verizon a été une belle course
ça va tu te fous taper la cloche oh oui
oh tout compte fait auparavant une bonne
heure voir demain comment non non non
non non non vous présenter